I'm a cyholic, a Cyworld fanatic.
Cyworld's temptations have me waking up with bloodshot eyes and headaches,...
...and have turned me into an exhibitionist and virtual cyber stalker.
I'm studying abroad and Cyworld is like an international telephone.
I use Cyworld's mini home pages to both keep in touch with friends,...
...and regrettably, to spy on my ex - boyfriend.
I try not to visit my own home page every day but I can't help myself.
My new free cyber - home has so many wonderful features.
It also came with an avatar called "mini me" who is my alter ego.
I spend hours changing its...
...facial expression, body position, hair, and clothing.
The more people visit me,...
...the more I feel I constantly need to do something to keep them coming.
Those page visit numbers give me an incentive...
...spend both money and time decorating my electronic home.
Cyworld displays your popularity on your front page,...
...which makes you constantly want to upgrade your page.
Cyworld knows that Koreans tend to be ambitious and ostentatious.
They use social engineering knowledge to measure your "success".
They know I like having my "fame" increase each time ten people visit me.
My self-esteem is tied to "sexiness", "friendliness",...
..."karma" and "kindness" statistics.
It's so easy to get lost in the pseudo love and affection Cyworld offers...
...and not easy to find a way back to the world.